just heard jack talking about
byoa bring your own algorithm to the
party what a great idea
uh from wolfram uh of fa wolf from al
from fame uh
mathematician search engine mathematics
mathematica thank you
um what do you guys think right off the
bat
of byoa oh yeah so it is
to me this is the corner of the thing
that
like tech nerds love to be like oh
that's a great solution for the problem
but the general public
will never adopt like the general public
i get i don't have no
analytics on this but i guarantee you
the people who are clicking the button
to switch back and forth
between home and latest on twitter is
like
sub five percent probably sub one
percent and it's like the people who are
listening to this
and if they actually do it every day
right but like if they added an ability
to modularly load in
your own you know dot tw
algo or something that that's like a new
file format that
that lets you you know pick how you want
your feed to be sorted like this is a
browser extension in 2005 type market
yeah what do you think david i have a
slightly different take on that actually
well ben i think you're right like i
think nobody this is like a product idea
that's
half baked but it was interesting we're
gonna talk about this in a minute we
just had
former twitter ceo de costello on
acquired one of the insights that came
from that
from him in that episode that i hadn't
realized like
twitter knows what's going on right like
they know
that facebook and now facebook and
instagram and whatsapp are the
juggernaut and they're
the number two player like they're avis
facebook is hertz
so like what do you do when you're avis
you do
different stuff like you're constantly
trying to change the game this is why
they did periscope this is why they did
vine this is why they did twitter music
like
all this stuff and this is a classic
example right of
if twitter were to actually do like
facebook is never never gonna change
never gonna let users change the
algorithm like that is their golden
goose like and so if twitter is willing
to change this they're just trying to do
stuff that like
facebook can't respond to
i think this could be interesting as
well in terms of if you think about the
browser wars
uh or search engine wars both of those
things the government did step in
depending on the region you're in
obviously in the us we had the microsoft
case with
explorer their browser versus netscape
and they said hey you can't really
bundle this stuff
and part of the settlement was hey you
get to pick your browser
and then i think in europe now they're
sort of saying hey when the browser
loads pick your search engine
and that might be a really easy way for
this google action that just came out
with apple an easy way to parse that
which is hey you know you load your
browser
anytime you load a new browser even if
google's paid
some carriage fee or whatever it just
presents you every year or every new
install with pick your
search engine and it has the top six
search engines there
and you pick one of them duckduckgo bang
whatever yahoo
this could become like you you load up
your twitter you load up and it says do
you want
which algorithm do you want do you want
the google algorithm because you could
take the google algorithm
and put it on twitter yeah that could be
really interesting to have a google and
bing algorithm that indexes those
services
well twitter has this history too of
third parties right like
there was always that that was that was
it was also a bane of their existence
for a long time but
yeah they've always created this uh you
know ethos that like
people can build on top of or into
twitter